[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebe freunde das die russische
föderation ein land krasser gegensätze
ist die allein schon aus den vielen
russischen lebens und videos die zum
ausgelassenen fremdschämen einladen denn
dieses ist früchte einer gesellschaft
die schon lange zwischen krassen
extremen oszilliert einerseits liegt die
große mehrheit seiner fast 150 millionen
einwohner in armut andererseits ist
eines der länder mit größtem
internationalen einfluss er gebietet mit
euch in russland noch immer zu den
potenziellen supermächten russlands
einfluss beruht natürlich nicht auf
wirtschaftliche macht immerhin macht
seine wirtschaft weniger als zwei
prozent des globalen
bruttoinlandsprodukts aus es gibt dort
keine unternehmen die global besonders
relevant wären und zu allem überfluss
war die wirtschaftliche entwicklung im
riesenreich in den letzten jahren nicht
gerade berauschend es ist also sich die
wirtschaft an der russland seinen
politischen einfluss test macht sondern
vielmehr seine militärische macht
[Musik]
und auch wenn das ausland militärisch
immer weiter hinter die vereinigten
staaten zurück fällt gibt es nach wie
vor als militärische großmacht nummer
zwei auf der welt auch wenn dieser platz
bald von china eingenommen
die russische armee verfügt über etwa
900.000 aktive soldaten und zwei
millionen reservisten
diese zahl hat sich im laufe der jahre
deutlich verringert die aktive
truppenstärke der sowjetunion betrug
einst mehr als vier millionen mann aber
nach wie vor setzt ladepunkten am knopf
des weltweit größten atomwaffenarsenals
mitsamt modernster
interkontinentalraketen denn russland
ist in erster linie ein land das um
dieses atom auf national und seine
streitkräfte herum geschmiedet wurde
damit du dir eine vorstellung davon
machen kannst nach den vorliegenden
berechnungen verfügt dieses land auch
heute noch über einen bestand von fast
6.500 punkte
[Musik]
aber freunde diese können zu allen ihr
gefühl sein und den fall der russischen
armee scheint dies der fall zu sein denn
wie du selbst haben die russen obwohl
das blanke zahlenwerk und um die
dimension ihrer streitkräfte
atemberaubend anmutet ein riesiges
problem den veralteten zustand ihrer
waffen panzer u-boote und anderer
konflikte bei einer offenen
auseinandersetzung gegen die vereinigten
staaten würde putins russland wirklich
ganz schön alt aussehen und dieser
minderwertigkeitskomplexe wurde in den
letzten jahren zu einer wahren obsession
moskaus nicht zuletzt weil die russische
militär industrie für das ganze land
sehr wichtig ist es geht um prestige und
sehr viel geld wie das land als ganzes
und natürlich auch für viele seiner
politiker und oligarchen du hast
wahrscheinlich schon wie die dinge in
solchen situationen laufen tatsache ist
dass die russische militär industrie die
zweitwichtigste nach der der vereinigten
staaten ist sie ist für mehr als zwei
millionen arbeiter verantwortlich war
ist nicht mehr oder weniger als drei
prozent der gesamten erwerbsbevölkerung
dort 20 prozent aller
industriearbeitsplätze des landes
ausmacht mit ausnahme der
rohstoffindustrie ist die
rüstungsindustrie daher eine der
wichtigsten wirtschaftlichen aktivitäten
der russischen föderation und ein
wichtiger aktivposten in den
internationalen beziehungen genau
deshalb werden wir in diesem video
erzählen wie es um die russische armee
wirklich bestellt ist und auch welche
pläne moskauer hegt um seine stellung
als zweitgrösste militärmacht des
planeten also klar vor china abzusichern
bist du bereit zu einer reise in dieses
gewaltige land um seine größte stärke
und gleichzeitig größte schwäche kennen
zu lernen und dann lasst uns anfangen
[Musik]
die große peinlichkeit
bevor wir uns aber auf das militär
russland heute stürzen wollen wir die
immer einen kurzen blick zurück in die
geschichte werfen denn um zu verstehen
wie diese geschichte wird dann müssen
wir in die jahre der sowjetunion
zurückgehen die udssr war während ihrer
gesamten existenz ein sehr armes land
ein sehr armes land mit einer riesigen
industriellen basis eine industrielle
basis die merkwürdigerweise zu jeder
zeit auf krieg vorbereitet war das heißt
alles sowjetischen verbrechen hatten
notfallpläne und bei bedarf waffen und
militärische ausrüstung zu produzieren
damit stand die gute ist dass er während
ihres gesamten bestehens quasi immer nur
einen kleinen schritt vor der
kriegswirtschaft lasst uns mal einen
blick auf ein paar daten werfen zum
zeitpunkt des untergangs verfügte der
militärisch industrielle komplex des
sowjetischen riesenreichs über 4000
militärische produktions und
forschungseinrichtungen beschäftigte 6
millionen menschen und verbrauchtes fast
50 prozent des gesamten central
staatlichen budgets ja du hast richtig
gehört 40 prozent des gesamten
staatshaushalt im grunde also eine
vollständige kriegswirtschaft ein
wirtschaftssystem das nicht zu sehr auf
das wohl seiner bürger ausgerichtet ist
sondern auf die vernichtung jedes
potenziellen gegners nun ging aber mehr
als die hälfte dieser riesigen
militärisch-industriellen macht nach dem
zerfall der udssr verloren da sie
finanziell einfach nicht mehr tragbar
war schließlich war es der verträge
losgetretene rüstungswettlauf der dsr
bis zum anschlag ausgelaugt und in eine
ruinöse wirtschaftskrise getrieben hatte
eine krise in der russland allein
zwischen 1991 und 93 20 prozent seines
bruttoinlandsprodukts verloren
diese krise war so groß und hatte so
gewaltige auswirkungen dass die
russische föderation ist bis 2004 nicht
schaffte das bip das sowjet ära zu
erreichen und auf dem weg dorthin
erlebte die militärindustrie an
apokalypse
fast 70 prozent der us unternehmen
verschwanden und der sektor verlor mehr
als dreieinhalb millionen arbeitsplätze
60 prozent seiner belegschaft und das
war noch nicht alles denn darüber hinaus
fertigt einen großteil der
produktionsstätten außerhalb der neuen
grenz markus lanz in ländern die nach
der auflösung des und wird uns völlig
unabhängig war
in ländern wie der ukraine in der
insgesamt fünf prozent der gesamten
britischen industrieproduktion
beheimatet war und in der tat war dieses
detail von zentraler bedeutung und eine
der höchsten prioritäten der russischen
außenpolitik denn die betriebe und
einrichtungen des militärisch
industriellen komplexes waren
geografisch über die gesamte suite
zerstreut die wirtschaftliche
interdependenz war in dieser hinsicht
mit morgen so dass russland nach dem
zerfall der udssr vor allem doppelten
problem stand erstens hat die krise die
bereits erwähnt seine industrielle
kapazitäten erheblich geschwächt
zweitens waren die verbliebenen
rüstungsfirmen und die armee stark von
lieferungen technologie und ausrüstung
abhängig die sich nun in den händen
anderer länder gefangen und alice
erklärt im großen und ganzen als große
interesse russlands die kontrolle über
einige der ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken
wie der kleine aufrechtzuerhalten aber
das ist ein thema für ein anderes region
zurück zur russischen militär armenien
haben so eine lästige eigenschaft man
muss nämlich ständig in sie investieren
um sie auf den neuesten stand der
technik zu halten nach dem zerfall der
udssr hatte russland jedoch einfach kein
geld mehr dafür
aus diesem grund betrogen die russischen
militärausgaben im jahr 1998 nur ein
drittel der ausgaben von 992 das
verteidigungsbudget fiel von fast 40
milliarden dollar auf knapp 16
milliarden und wider der sich ja
vorstellen kannst ging diese
haushaltskürzungen mit einem eindruck
der militärischen produktion einher bis
zum jahr 1999 war die russische
rüstungsproduktion auf nur noch ein
zehntel dessen geschrumpft was noch 91
produziert worden
das musst du dir mal auf der zunge
zergehen lassen nur noch zehn prozent
der ursprünglichen größe ein einbruch
ungeheuren ausmaßes aber warte ein
moment denn mit der ankunft des neuen
jahrtausends begann sich alles zu ändern
mit dem einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
trat einer der großen produkte
listen der internationalen politik die
bühne du hast wahrscheinlich von weniger
sprechen wladimir putin präsident der
von einigen bereits als der neue star
angesehen wird
als putin im jahr 2000 an die macht kam
befanden sich die russischen
streitkräfte in einer katastrophalen
situation nur 20 prozent der
militärischen ausrüstung waren relativ
neu und überhaupt funktionsfähig und
nicht nur das auch mobilität und
reaktionsfähigkeit der armee befanden
sich an einen historischen tiefpunkt
diese probleme bestehen in vielen fällen
bis heute fort zum beispiel was
flugzeugträger angeht flugzeugträger
sind eine der wichtigsten und
entscheidendste waffengattungen eines
staates der real als weltmacht agieren
möchte denn sie sind seegestützte
luftwaffenbasen welche militäraktionen
weit außerhalb des eigenen territoriums
ermöglichen nicht umsonst sagte bill
clinton einmal immer wenn sie sich eine
internationale krise anbahnt ist ist
kein zufall dass in washington als
allererstes die frage gestellt wird wo
ist der nächste flugzeugträger
stationiert und während die vereinigten
staaten zu beginn des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert seine flotte von 14 dieser
schiffe rund um den globus unterhielten
hat der russland gerade mal ein einziges
schiff welches gerade noch so als
flugzeugträger durchgehen kann
oder drücken wir es mal so aus die ist
eine russische schiff war extrem weit
davon entfernt zu spitze der
flugzeugträger gezielt zu werden
[Musik]
denn bei dieser angeradelt kuznetsov
klasse handelt es sich um einen
flugzeugträger typ aus der endphase der
udssr mit einer technologie aus den
frühen 80er jahren welche jedoch
aufgrund verschiedener mängel erst 998
voll einsatzfähig war
aber das ist nicht das einzige beispiel
dass wir dafür finden dass das russische
militär auf dem papier gewöhnlich besser
aussieht als in der realität ein
weiteres beispiel von mehr schein als
sein finden wir in russischen panzer
bestand offiziell verfügt russland über
die größte panzertruppe der welt
schätzungen zufolge 15 20.000 einheiten
mehr als alle nato-staaten
zusammengenommen aber die meisten dieser
panzer sind alt sehr alt viele von ihnen
sind ganz einfach ehemalige sowjetische
panzer aus den 60er und 70er jahren
und wenn du dir sicher vorstellen kann
es ergeben sich darauf ist viele
schwächen
diese kam zum beispiel während des
krieges oder besser gesagt werde ist
angriffs auf georgien im jahr 2008 zum
vorschein
der georgien krieg war auslands erster
offener krieg nach dem fall der
sowjetunion und er dient quasi dazu die
effektivität seiner ausrüstung und die
fähigkeiten seiner armee zu testen und
die wahrheit ist nun mal das ausland
krabbelt durch diese prüfung fiel alle
wirklichen probleme tauchten auf
mangelnde koordination zwischen den
befehlshabern mangel an präzisionswaffen
schlechte wartung der militärischen
ausrüstung und die grottenschlechte
ausbildung des gesamten personals dies
führte trotz der enormen zahlenmäßigen
überlegenheit muss man es zu einem
extrem zäh voran kommen überwiegend
georgier und die russische armee
verzeichnete viel größere verluste als
sie ursprünglich angenommen hatte all
dies war ein großes debatte himmel der
und plötzlich mit einer fakten realität
konfrontiert wurde denn es wurde klar
seine streitkräfte waren alles andere
als auf dem level einer supermacht
[Musik]
und wenn schon der einmarsch in ein
kleines land georgien dass sich nicht
einmal die mühe gemacht hat ich dich
widerstand zu leisten
durch eine ständige abfolge von problem
und da gab's alle angst verbunden war
das würde im falle einer viel
umfangreicheren operation geschenkt hast
du dir vorstellen was passiert wäre wenn
es zu einer konfrontation mit nato
truppen gekommen wäre
nun in moskau schritten damals genau aus
diesem grund alle alarmglocken auf mann
war aus seiner großes fantasie in einer
realität der stark bedingten
verteidigungsfähigkeit erwacht der
schock saß so tief dass putin weitere
drei jahre brauchte um im jahr 2011 ein
umfassendes programm zur modernisierung
der russischen streitkräfte vorzustellen
dieses hat er ist dann aber in sich und
sollte zur höchsten nationalen priorität
russlands werden wir sprechen über das
so genannte sap statement programm also
ein stars auf rüstungsprogramm das eine
gigantische investitionen von bis zu 650
milliarden dollar vorsah und neue
flugzeuge panzer und vor allem u boot
raketen und marschflugkörper zu kaufen
und zu entwickeln
all dies mit dem ziel dass bis zum jahr
2020 mindestens 70 prozent der
waffensysteme als moderne und voll
einsatzfähig angesehen werden können so
weit so gut aber ein moment mal wir
haben ja bereits das jahr 2020 egal dann
können wir uns ja jetzt zurücklehnen und
die grandiosen ergebnisse dieses super
programms bestaunen holt schon mal das
buch
stolpersteine
also wie sieht's aus hat sich die
russische armee in den letzten 25 jahren
erheblich verbessert
es gab ein paar ergebnisse die den
modernisierungsplan der russischen armee
etwas durcheinander gebracht haben zb
der krieg in der ukraine und die
alexianer können diese militäraktion
führten so fucking sanktionen durch die
usa und viele andere westliche länder
gegen russland sanktionen welche vor
allem die russische rüstungsindustrie
aufs korn nahmen aber nicht nur das die
aus dem euro meiden hervorgegangene neue
regierung in der ukraine widersetze sich
der russischen kontrolle so dass moskau
den direkten zugang zu einigen seiner
wichtigsten militär lieferanten verlor
der ukrainischen flugzeughersteller
antonow sollte den russischen
verteidigungsministerium zb neue
militärische transportflugzeuge vom typ
78 und 124 zufriedenstellen und ausland
war auch auch lieferverträge für
wichtige komponenten wie triebwerke der
flugzeuge hubschrauber das ist es
hersteller mit
und ja komplett auf die ukraine
angewiesen
aber diese lieferverträge lösten sich in
luft auf ebenso wie die verträge über
die lieferung von komponenten und
technologie für das russische programm
zur fregatten modernisieren
diese ausfälle führten zu ernsthaften
störungen der russischen und
modernisierungspläne und bedeutendsten
waren sie neue fregatten der andere alte
coach klasse deren gasturbinen vor der
ukrainischen firma tori amos projekt
hergestellt und alle diese verträge
wurden von der ukrainischen regierung
nach der invasion natürlich ausgesetzt
wodurch russland gezwungen war sich nach
alternativen lieferanten umzusehen
entweder im land selbst oder aus ihnen
noch freundlich gesinnten ländern
doch das ist kein leichtes unterfangen
sowohl was die entwicklungsstandards als
auch was die kopplung mit bestehenden
systemen und wichtig logische
kompatibilität betrifft
und das ist noch nicht alles nach den
ereignissen in der ukraine und den
anschließenden internationalen stationen
stopp nicht vereinigten staaten und
viele verbündete länder den verkauf von
elektronischen komponenten mit doppeltem
verwendungszweck also zivil und
militärisch wie spezialglas stahl welche
zur herstellung große schaffen und
satelliten verwendet wurden und für die
moskauer jedes jahr etwa 500 millionen
dollar ausgab und das alles hat schon zu
einer gewaltigen zahl an rückschlägen
führt aber konzentrieren wir uns mal auf
die ergebnisse und die waffensysteme
über die russland derzeit verfügt und da
muss man schon eingestehen
trotz der enormen anstrengungen bestehen
die alten probleme nach wie vor
schätzungsweise nur 50 prozent der
bodentruppen können als moderne
betrachtet werden nehmen wir zum
beispiel den fall der russischen b 14
bei martha panzer das kronjuwel und die
schlüssel waffen zur modernisierung der
russischen bodentruppen
ursprünglich hatte moskau geplant bis
zum jahr 2025 über rund 2300 panzer
dieses typs nur verfügen das budget
wurde jedoch so verbessert dass am ende
aus diesen 2300 konzern tatsächlich nur
132 wurden
und wenn die situation in den zuvor
beschriebenen postsowjetischen krisen
schon extrem düster auf mich gewirkt hat
dann für es nicht dass die heutigen
perspektiven kaum besser sender der
momentan befindet sich russland mitten
in einer doppelten krise zu 1 in einer
wirtschafts und währungskrise
der opel musste in den letzten zehn
jahren 60 prozent gegenüber den dollar
abwerten und zum anderen befindet sich
russland in einer diplomatischen krise
welche das land von wichtigen märkten
die für die modernisierung des
verkehrssektors notwendig wären
abgeschnitten hat ja das alles klingt
nicht gerade nach einer erfolgsstory
aber jetzt kommt das große aber denn
obwohl wichtige ziele des sap-systems
programms im zeitraum 2011 bis 2020
nicht erreicht worden handelte es sich
dennoch um die phase der größten
russischen realisierungs
kraftanstrengung seit dem fall dessen
wird union
[Musik]
und für einen boden liegendes land waren
doch einige erstaunliche erfolge zu
vermelden
die russische luftwaffe bekam 100
brandneues suchoi su 35 dieses
mehrzweckkampfflugzeug kommt
spezifikation suisse sicht durchaus an
die neuesten amerikanischen und
europäischen modelle heran
darüber hinaus wurden zehn alte
sowjetische atombombe tupolew 160
aufgerüstet überholte variante heißt tu
160 und bei der marine russlands größte
schwachstelle hat das programm den
nuklearen geboten der b klasse mit 16
raketenwerfern die jeweils sechs
nuklearer sprengköpfe tragen können
absoluten vorrang eingeräumt und das
liebe freunde ist wahrhaft kein
pappenstiel denn die kosten für bau und
ausrüstung nur eines dieser u-boote
belaufen sich auf fast eine milliarde
dollar
sie sind das neue kronjuwelen des
russischen personals und heute sind
bereits wieder voll auf den meeren
unterwegs das sap rüstungsprogramme ist
also noch lange nicht abgeschlossen es
gab viele verzögerungen und
stolpersteine
aber die russen mussten ja schon immer
zu improvisieren und der modernisierungs
sprung ist in einigen bereichen durchaus
nicht zu leugnen was aber dennoch bleibt
ist eine schlüsselfrage an welcher sich
die zukunft all diese pläne entscheidet
du möchtest wissen was dieser
schlüsselfrage ist nur was ich meine ist
dass die militärische schlagkraft einer
armee und zutage unglaublich stark von
der industriellen kapazität eines landes
abhängt bzw
da innerhalb von waffensysteme
lieferketten verbündeten länder und für
länder die russland steht und fällt ihr
einfluss auf der weltbühne mit der
fähigkeit moderne ausrüstungen auf
grundlage dieser komplexen lieferketten
herzustellen und zu verkaufen
das alles wird noch kritischer wenn das
land eine strukturelle wirtschaftskrise
durchgemacht die bände frage lautet also
worin liegt das wirkliche problem der
russischen militärs trieben nun darauf
gibt es eine eindeutige antwort die
größte schwäche ist ihre enorme
ineffizienz russlands rüstung sie ist in
erster linie zentralistisch organisiert
und staatlich gelenkt und das liebe
freunde verursacht so viele probleme wie
zb eine viel geringere flexibilität und
geschwindigkeit der technologischen
entwicklung dieses problem lässt
russland immer weiter nicht nur hinter
die usa sein ob in der china
zurückgefallen
schauen wir uns also ein beispiel an das
veranschaulicht worüber gesprächen
nehmen wir den fall des russischen
militär unternehmens prospekt rostek ist
dann nehmen das ist knapp über 45
milliarden dollar das macht und 529 1000
mitarbeiter beschäftigt sein us-rivale
lockheed martin hat 405.000 beschäftigte
fünfmal weniger und erwirtschaftet
dennoch mehr als 53 57 milliarden dollar
umsatz was fast doppelt so viel ist aber
vielleicht fragst du dich jetzt ob das
wirklich so wichtig und entscheidend ist
nun sagen wir es ist ein zeichen dafür
dass irgendwas faul ist russische
unternehmen sind riesige konzerne sehr
bürokratisch und kompliziert und sie
werden durch eine doppelaufgabe belastet
sie sollen nicht nur modernste waffen
entwickeln und herstellen sondern auch
wie jedes mit dem start verbundene
unternehmen aus wahltaktischen gründen
so viele arbeitsplätze wie möglich im
ganzen land schaffen aber sie agieren
nun mal nicht in einer welt und
beschränkter ressourcen und wenn ein
großer teil des budgets von unter
qualifizierten sesselpupser und
politisch besetzten östlichen
aufgefressen wird sinkt die fähigkeit
einer firma die besten talente
anzuziehen und zu halten
diese gehen natürlich mehr zur
ausländischen firmen mit einer besseren
firmenkultur und das alles führt mit der
zeit zu einer abwärtsspirale der
inkompetenz und einer immer größeren
technologischen prüft
[Musik]
vergesst bitte nicht dass sich der
waffenmarkt nicht allzu sehr von jedem
anderen markt unterscheidet
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und innovation sind
der schlüssel zu langfristigem erfolg
und echte wettbewerbsfähigkeit erzeugt
man nur was man wettbewerb auch wirklich
zu lässt ja und genau diese tatsache hat
nun scheinbar auch wladimir putin
begriffen denn diese kernprobleme des
alten sap rüstungsprogramms von 2011 bis
2020 haben ihn dazu geführt einen neuen
plan mit einem fast identischen budget
anzukündigen den staatlichen
rüstungskonzerns 2027 aber im gegensatz
zu dem von 2011 wurde die direkte
steuerung der mittel und ressourcen
durch den staat nun wesentlich begrenzt
man darf also gespannt sein ob sich
damit das verlorene potenzial der
russischen rüstungsgeschäft wieder
zurück gewinnen lässt
[Musik]
auf jeden fall habe die russische
streitkräfte wählte ära von planet
punkten eine gewaltige umgestaltung
erfahren
dennoch stehen sie auch heute noch vor
drei großen problem erstens ist ihre
ausrüstung im vergleich mit anderen
ländern noch immer in der breite
veraltet es gibt ein paar lichtblicke
welche die russische regierung umso
stolzer präsentiert aber die sind eher
ein paar ausnahmen welche die regel
bestätigen und nichts am allgemeinen
zustand ändern
zweitens ist die russische militär
industrie nachricht sehr ineffizient und
bürokratisch sich für den wettbewerb mit
us militär unternehmen und neun akteuren
wie china immer weiter zurück und
drittens wird die strukturelle
wirtschaftskrise des landes ernsthafte
zweifel an seiner fähigkeit auf die
modernisierung und den betrieb seiner
streitkräfte weiterhin finanzieren zu
können aber die bisherigen bemühungen
der regierung putin haben russland
immerhin auf ein level gebracht auf dem
es immer noch als potenzielles vormacht
gelten kann und das ist doch immerhin
etwas an dem ende der 90er jahre doch
ernsthafte zweifel bestanden so und
jetzt bist du dran
glaubst du dass russland so stark und
furchteinflößend ist wie die moskauer
propaganda uns glauben machen will kann
mehr wettbewerb und geringere staatliche
einfluss und rüstungssektor zu einer
umkehr des brain trains türen oder
werden die politischen kosten der
effizienzsteigerungen in den
rüstungsunternehmen zu hoch ausfallen
als das sie die regierung putin weiter
tragen könnte schreib uns deine meinung
bitte die immer andy kommentar zahlen zu
diesem video wir hoffen dass dieses
video etwas gebracht hat falls ja gibt
uns bitte auch einen daumen hoch und
beschlüsse uns indem du es mit deinem
volk heißt vergisst wird auch nicht dass
wir jede woche neue videos hochladen
also verpasst keines unserer updates
abonniere unseren kanal und klicke auf
das klingeln um rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt zu werden was gut und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]